Qué significa abandonarse tratado y
además Qué implicaciones tiene esta
medida tomada por Putin
siempre pensando en el conflicto de
Ucrania como una guerra simétrica hay
que pensar que el efecto es más
discursivo retórico que efectivo Pese a
que el Start que es el acrónimo para
tratado estratégico de reducción de
armas nucleares había sido digamos una
continuidad de pasos en los cuales las
potencias nucleares demostraban desde
los 90 la voluntad de reducir
fehacientemente el volumen de su Arsenal
y con ello limitar también el riesgo de
daño y de un conflicto atómico ahora
salir del Star 3 que básicamente fue la
ratificación en 2020 del tratado que ya
en 2012 firmó en Moscú implica por
supuesto mensaje de que Rusia está
dispuesta a tomar medidas extremas en
caso de que como bien lo ha dicho
en el conflicto de
ahora Cuál ha sido el impacto a la
contribución del New Star desde su
creación en 2010
respecto de el New Start 2 el New Start
3 había implicado una reducción de un
75% del volumen de los arsenales
nucleares de manera pactada eso Por
supuesto dentro del marco de la
verificación de los árbitros de las
Naciones Unidas de aquello sin embargo
aún así el el Arsenal atómico de ambos
países es de cierta manera un Arsenal
considerable y el renunciar en este
momento a los avances que habían habido
les recuerdo que del 91 al 2002 del
estar uno al estar dos por ejemplo había
habido una reducción de un 30% de la
capacidad nuclear Más allá de lo que
hayamos reducido hasta 2020 salir ahora
implica por supuesto una amenaza que
está ligada a lo que ya la iglesia
ortodoxa rusa y el vicepresidente o el
jefe de gobierno han dicho no en las
últimas horas y es que Rusia de serle al
verso el conflicto en Ucrania podría
escalar esto otro tipo de
señor Fajardo realmente afectará esta
medida la forma en que se tiene control
sobre las armas nucleares
ciertamente es un acuerdo de buena
voluntad del estar no garantizaba más de
lo que va a garantizar la salida de
Rusia la posibilidad de no usar armas
nucleares hay una especie de
racionalidad dentro del marco del
entendimiento geopolítico que ha
imperado los últimos 20 años lo que está
en riesgo es esa racionalidad y lo que
me parece que en el marco también de los
retórico el presidente Putin está
haciendo es amenazar con un tantrum con
una pataleta una pataleta que por
supuesto sería letal con irse de la
guerra pateando la mesa diríamos en
términos comunicacionales y y esto
implica el decir que se aleja del
tratado Star 3 implica el expresarle a
la Unión Europea y también a los Estados
Unidos que el conflicto si se sale de El
marco de lo binacional entre Ucrania y
Rusia claramente puede tener
consecuencias adversas para todo el
mundo